hello everyone in this video I will be
showing you how to make a flappy bird
type game in scratch for those of you
who don't know what scratch is scratch
is a block based programming language
where you can drag and drop blocks to
create projects it's more of an
educational type of visual programming
language to teach children how to code
there's also a online community where
you can view other people's projects and
share your own anyways to get started go
to scratch.mit.edu which is the scratch
website once you're there you can either
create a new account by clicking the
join scratch button over here or scroll
down and download the offline editor
which is the same thing if you're using
the online version once you have created
an account you can click the create
button over here to start a new project
so let's start by creating the bird so
I'm gonna go to the costumes of this
scratch cat and I'm gonna delete the
second one and I'm going to clear this
one and I'll draw my own bird so I'll
start by creating a circle let's see
about this size I think now I'm going to
add a black outline to it right here -
maybe a I think size 5 is good I'll
decrease the circle a little bit though
maybe - this big all right and since I'm
making a bird I'll make it yellow on the
inside so about this color alright so
let's see now I'll draw the eye so I'm
drawing an another circle I'll make it
this big and I'll position this right
over here okay
I'll actually make this fill black and
I'll keep that outline so yeah now I'm
going to draw a beak so I'll draw two
lines like this
and I'll make the fill yellow actually
the same color as the bird so this and
then I got to make sure the beak is
under the bird so I'm going to shift it
backwards like that and I think I'm
going to add some legs so I'll just draw
some quick lines like this and there so
yeah this is a really quick drawing I
don't want to spend too much time
drawing so that's why I quickly created
a bird so yeah anyways now I am done and
I'm going to go back to the code and now
let's start coding the bird so I want
the bird to be able to jump when I press
the mouse button so to do that let's go
to the event and then drag this wind fly
clicked onto here and now let's go to
control and then grab a forever loop and
I'm going to drag an if-then statement
and then I'm going to go to sensing
that's where the mouse down stuff is
then I'll drag the mouse down into the
if-then so pretty much what happens is
that when I press the green flag
then this keeps checking if the mouse is
down so now we want to actually do stuff
when the mouse is down so first of all
we want the bird to be affected by
gravity so pretty much when the bird
falls it falls faster and faster over
time so to do that we actually have to
create a variable so let's go to
variables and let's create one let's
call this Y velocity and let's select
for the sprite only so pretty much this
variable is only or actually can only be
used by the bird so now let's click OK
and what our Y philosophy variable is
going to do is that it's going to be the
speed of the bird in the Y position
which is up and down so pretty much if
our Y velocity is going to be three then
the bird is going to move upwards
constantly at three units and if our Y
velocity is let's say negative ten
then our bird is going to move downwards
constantly by ten units however we want
the bird to move downwards faster and
faster right we want the bird to fall
faster and faster over time so we're
going to actually be changing the Y
velocity which means that we're going to
be changing the speed in which the bird
moves down over time so it's like
gravity
so let's first set the Y velocity to
zero when the flag is clicked and okay
let's make the bird start over here so
that's like let's go to motion so
negative one seventy two and zero in the
Y position and then let's see so what we
want is that we want the Y position of
the bird to be always changing
by the Y velocity variable or the speed
so I'm actually to make this more clear
I'm going to rename the Y velocity
variable to change in Y so I think
that's easier to understand but anyways
let's go back to the motion blocks and
what I'm gonna do is drag a change Y
block drag it inside of the forever loop
and then I'll go to variables and drag
the change in Y variable inside of the
change Y by block so what this is is
that the Y position of the bird is
always going to change by the change in
Y so now we have to set the values for
the change in Y so if we press the mouse
button we want to set the change in Y by
let's say nine so pretty much what
happens is that when we click then the
speed of the bird will be going upwards
by nine and it would keep going up so
let's try it out when we press then it
keeps going up like that
so yeah but now of course we want the
bird to fall so what we can do is
actually just drag a change change in Y
by block and put it in the forever loop
and let's change it by let's say
negative 0.8 sorry negative 0.8 so since
there is gravity we always want the bird
to be going downwards so now let's try
it out
now as you can see it works there's
gravity because the bird keeps going
down by negative 0.8 and then when we
press the mouse button then the speed of
the bird changes to 9 so um yeah that's
a really simple jumping script we have
right here and anyways that will do it
for right now for the bird so now let's
create our pipes where the birds going
to go through so let's click the button
over here and let's create a new sprite
so I'm just gonna draw some simple pipes
let's see I'm going to draw a rectangle
like this and I'm going to make the
pipes green and all right and now I'm
going to add another rectangle put it
right here like this okay I'll make the
pipes a bit thicker all right okay
cool all right so this is going to be
the top pipe and now we want the bottom
pipe so let's create a new costume
actually um let's duplicate this one and
then I'm gonna flip it so let's select
the entire thing and then let's flip
vertically and now we have the bottom
pipe alright so we have to the top and
the bottom pipe so let's first name
these I'll name this top pipe and this
one bottom pipe and alright let's go
back to the code so of course we want a
win site clicked and what we want is
that we want this sprite to be creating
copies of the top and bottom pipe
because we're gonna have more than one
pipe on the screen at any given time so
just to make it easier to manage we
don't want the actual sprite to show so
let's go to looks and then hide the
sprite when the flag is clicked and now
we we want the sprite to keep creating
clones so let's go to control and then
drag a forever loop and let's go to
events oops sorry not events of control
and let's drag a crepe clone of myself
and put it inside of the forever loop so
it's gonna keep creating clones of the
pipe and we actually wanted to create
two clones of the pipe because we have a
top and the bottom pipe so if we try it
right now then it's only gonna create
clones of the bottom pipe
so of course the pipes aren't shown but
anyways if we do show the pipes
let's just drag it when they start as a
clone and also a show then the pipes are
there's like tons of clones of the pipes
like that but we want this sprite to
simultaneously create the top and bottom
pipes
so let's actually first create a
variable and let's name this
or top pipe I guess and make sure to
select for this right only this is very
important otherwise it won't work so
select for this fight only and then
click OK
and now what we want to do is to set
bottom or top pipe and then drag it to
the forever loop right before it creates
a clone of itself and let's set it to
top and then let's duplicate this and
then put it under here and then we want
to set bottom or top pipe to bottom
and then in create clone of itself again
so I'll explain to you later what this
does but pretty much the clone is going
to use this variable to know whether it
is the top or the bottom pipe so anyways
let's add a weight in here so let's go
to events actually a control and then
let's drag a way to 1 seconds and I'll
change this to maybe 3 seconds alright
and now in the when I start as a clone
we will want to show it and now we want
to add a if else statement so let's drag
that and we want to check if it's the
top pipe then it switches its costume to
the top pipe costume and if it's the
bottom pipe then it's going to switch
costume to the bottom pipe costume so
that's why we use this variable so let's
do that so let's go to operators grab an
equals operator drag inside of here and
let's go to variables grab the bottom or
top pipe variable put inside here and if
the bottom or top pipe variable is equal
to bottom make sure it's spelled the
same as how you spelled it here but if
it's bottom then we wanted to switch
costume to bottom pipe and else if it is
top then we switch costume to top pipe
so it's as simple as that now let's try
this out it's not gonna work but let's
just see how it is so far so as you can
see
actually spawns the top and bottom pipe
like that all right so now we want the
top and bottom pipes to actually be
positioned correctly we want the top
pipe right here and bottom pipe right
here so to do that for now let's just go
to motion and grab a go to put it after
the switch costume to bottom pipe and
for the bottom pipe let's let's see
let's make it go like right here for now
so we want to spawn at the edge of the
screen right because the pipes are going
to move from the right to the left
so exposition to 5/9 and y position
negative two one two all right
and for the top pipe let's see let's
make it spawn let's say right here so 2
5 9 and y position 54 all right so let's
try that for now so as you can see the
top and bottom pipes spawn like this and
now we want the top and bottom pipes to
move to the left side of the screen
right so to do this is to go to control
and grab a repeat until block let's put
that after the if-else statement so what
the repeat until block does is that it
keeps doing something as long as the
thing in here is true and then after the
thing in here is false then it runs the
code after so of course since we want
the blocks to disappear after reaching
the left side of the screen we want to
grab a operator let's grab a lesser than
operator then inside here and let's go
to motion grab the exposition block
right here drag it inside of the repeat
until operator and we want to check if
the exposition is less than a certain
number then the clones delete itself so
let's see let's first show the initial
sprite
and let's see right here so if the
exposition is less than negative 237
then the Clones should delete themselves
so let's go to a control and let's grab
a delete this clone and drag it after
the repeat into so of course we want the
pipes to be moving to the left until the
exposition is less than negative 237 so
let's go to a motion and let's grab a
change X by block and put it inside of
the repeat into and let's change it by
let's say negative 5 so we want the
pipes to move towards the left by 5
units until it reaches the edge here and
then it hides so yeah let's try it out
and as you can see the pipes work like
that and we can like increase or
decrease the spawn rate so maybe you can
wait like one second and we can see
there's the pipes like this and they
also disappear once they touch it left
to edge of the screen and they appear
from the right so yeah the pipes seem to
be working
however we want spawning in the Y
position so to do that we actually have
to create a new variable so let's create
a new variable let's call it random Y
spawn I guess random Y spawn position
and let's select for the spy only and
then click OK so what we want to do is
to set a random Y position for the
blocks to spawn from so to do that let's
first drag this into this forever loop
before it creates clones of the pipes
and let's go to operators to grab the
pick random and put it inside of the set
random y spawn position and um let's see
let's maybe okay let's deal with this
but let's see the range in which the
pipes can spawn so I'm going to show the
original sprite and I'm gonna do some
testing so let's see I think the top
pipe should be right here around this
would be the highest point it can spawn
so that's why position 153 and the
lowest position for the bottom pipe is
gonna be let's say right here so
negative 284 so for now let's just put
in 1 what was it again
153 I think yeah 153 to negative 284 I
think let's just double-check yeah
something like that
all right so this is going to be the
range in which the pipes can spawn but
oh yeah one important thing I think to
make this easier let's go to the
costumes and make sure that the pipes
are actually positioned where we want
them so let's say let's copy this bottom
pipe and put it into the top pipe for
now and let's say we want our space to
be this big right then we want to make
sure that the top pipe and bottom pipe
are positioned like this in each of
their costumes so I'm gonna move this to
the middle right here okay I think this
is the middle alright so right here so
now I'm gonna delete the bottom pipe or
actually not yet I'm gonna first
duplicate this and then I'm gonna delete
the bottom pipe and now I'm gonna go to
my duplicate and then I'm gonna delete
the top pipe and now we don't need this
extra bottom pipe costume so yeah
anyways now we have the top pipe and
bottom pipe where we want them and I'm
gonna first rename this to bottom five
all right cool so of course you can
change the space in which is between the
top and bottom pipe so that's up to you
but yeah let's go back to the code now
and let's see let's find our range in Y
positions again now so let's see for the
top pipe I'd say Y position 79 and for
the bottom pipe
I'd say Y position negative 79 all right
that works well so now because I
repositioned these two pipes to where
want them it's now super easy so all you
have to do is to go to variables and
then drag the random Y spawnposition
into the go to X Y and in the Y so let's
drag that into here for both the top and
the bottom pipe and now let's try it out
so as you can see it works however the
pipes are entirely on the screen like
there's some empty space but of course
we can go to the costumes and change
that but at least the random Y position
works so as you can see they're spawned
randomly so to change or actually to fix
the problem let's go to costumes and all
we needed to do is to increase this
length of the rectangle so let's drag
this entire rectangle down here
and I'm going to drag this rectangle
upwards like this all right now I'm
gonna select the entire thing and then
drag it back up I think it was right
around here okay maybe a bit more
downwards yeah about right all right and
now let's do the same for the bottom
pipe move it up here drag the rectangle
down here and then drag the entire thing
back down
right around here I think so yeah all
right looks good okay I think this one's
positioned a bit to the left so I'll
move it back maybe this one a bit to the
left
all right cool so now let's run it and
as you can see the pipes now spawn like
this they're in a random Y position and
the entire pipe covers like both the top
and the bottom edges of the screen so
awesome I think I'm going to increase
the gap a bit because I don't think the
bird can go through like very easily or
if it's possible at all so let's
increase the gap and to do that it's
really simple you just move the top and
the bottom pipe upwards and downwards so
the top pipe upwards like this and the
bottom pipe downwards like this all
right and make sure your gap is equal on
both the top and the bottom compared to
the middle like over here versus over
here so yeah it looks about right now
let's try it
and now the gap is much larger so
awesome I'll make the bird a bit smaller
I think so I'll go back to the bird I'm
gonna go to looks and change the size or
set the size to maybe 80 okay I think
that's better so yeah now I think for
the bird it looks a bit like two still
when it jumps so I think I'm gonna
rotate it when it jumps so it looks like
it's actually flapping so to do that
let's just go to motion and drag a point
in direction and drag it under the if
Mouse down and I'm going to change it to
let's say 45 degrees and what this does
is that it's gonna change it to like
this when it jumps but of course we want
the bird to rotate back to its original
position which
90 degrees so let's just grab it if
statement and then put it inside of the
forever loop and let's go to operators
grab a lesser than operator and we want
to check if the direction which is in
the motions is less than 90 which was
its starting direction then we want it
to turn clockwise let's say three
degrees so pretty much if the bird is
like this then it's gonna keep rotating
until it faces the right so let's try it
out now as you can see there is some
motion with the bird so when it flaps it
sort of moves back like that so I think
it looks better like this and I might
change it to maybe turn four degrees so
let's try it all right I think that
looks much better
so yeah now let's make a simple lose
state so when the bird touches the pipes
then let's just stop the game for right
now so let's see let's drag a if
statement inside of the forever loop and
let's go to sensing and it's detect if
touching sprite - or the pipes then it's
gonna stalk all so let's go to control
and let's stop everything so let's try
it out and yeah when it touched a pipe
then the entire game stopped all right
so okay I'm gonna first hide all of my
variables all right so then I'll try it
again okay and when it touch the pipe
then the entire game stopped all right
cool okay and it's like this
okay um I think I'm going to add a
simple background so I'll go to
backdrops here go to costumes or
backdrops and then I'm going to fill it
or actually I'll convert to bitmap and
then I'll fill this maybe to light blue
let's see like this and all right now we
have some simple backdrop so um yeah
this is our completed game or actually
not completed but a completed working
game so all right cool let's see yeah
this is a bit hard right now but you
know you can tweak it to change the
difficulty to make it easier maybe so
yeah
this is part 2 on how to make a flappy
bird game in scratch in this tutorial I
will be creating an infinite scrolling
background and a scoring system so the
first thing I wanted to add that I
didn't do in the last video was to make
the bird be able to lose when it reaches
the bottom of the screen over here so to
do that it's actually really simple
let's go to operators and then grab and
or statement and let's put it over here
so if the bird is touching sprite to
which are the pipes or if the birds Y
position is less than a certain value
let's see if it's less than negative 171
then we want to stop the game so let's
try it out if the bird goes to the
bottom here then the game stops all
right so now that we're done with that
I'm going to start creating the
scrolling background so I was thinking
of maybe adding some hills in the
background and then making the moving
slowly to the left to make it look like
the bird is you know moving so let's do
that
so let's first create a new sprite and
now I'm going to draw my hills
all right so I'm done with my Hill and
what I did was that I just made a
rectangle across the entire drawing area
and then I use this v-shaped tool to you
know add a few points and then I just
moved these points around to make it
curvy all right so make sure that the
width of your hill is exactly the same
width as the drawing area no more or
less as you can see I made this very
exact so yeah and also make sure that
the height of the left edge over here is
the exact same height as the height of
the right edge over here anyways this
will do for now and let me go back to
the code so first off I'm going to grab
a win flag clicked in the events and
then I'm going to make the hills go to
zero zero so now to the center of the
screen and what I want is that I want
this hill to constantly move towards the
left so to do that let's go to control
grab a forever loop and then let's go to
motion grab the change X by block put it
inside of the for loop and let's say
let's change X by negative three alright
so we try it right now then the hill as
you can see always moves towards the
left by three units all right so since
I'm going to be testing this Hill a lot
I'm going to disconnect the code from
the chicken and the pipes so you know
it's only the hill and I'm also going to
hide the chicken all right so now this
is just the hill
so yeah alright cool so now that the
Hill moves now we want the hill to go
from the left edge of the screen to the
right edge of the screen once it reaches
the end over here so to do that let's
grab and if statement
and let's put this inside of the far
loop and we want to check if the
exposition of the
are less than a certain value so let's
go to operators grab a less than
operator go to motion grab an exposition
and let's check if the exposition is
less than negative 464 so what it did
was that I found the smallest possible
value for this right which is negative
465 and then I just added one so yeah
so once the exposition of the hills is
less than negative 464 then we wanted to
move to the right side of the screen so
since I made this hill the exact width
of the screen which is 480 pixels or
units then what I can do is just simply
set X to its current x position over
here multiplied by a negative one so
let's go to operators grab the negative
1 operator drag it inside of the set X 2
and then go to motion grab the
exposition and type in negative 1 all
right so let's try it out once the hill
reaches the left side of the screen then
it teleports to the right side all right
so it works it's infinite like this
let's see it again
and all right it works so oh yeah one
thing I noticed was that it's not very
smooth as you can see here you can see
that it sort of gets cut off early
before it it teleports to the right side
so I don't really want that to happen
let's say it again as you can see it
doesn't completely go off the screen so
that's sort of something that scratch
has and to actually fix the issue
I'm just going to go to looks and grab a
set size to block and the right before
it changes X by negative 3 and checks if
the x position is less than negative 4
64 I'm going to set size to 150 percent
and right - after the hill moves and
checks for all the stuff then I'm gonna
set the size back to a hundred percent
so like this before all of your code put
in set size to 1 to 50% and then right
after put set size to 100% so this is
sort of complicated to explain but
pretty much what this does is that the
set size makes the hills bigger then
it's actually supposed to be which is
100 percent so right before it moves it
can technically go off screen but then
right after it moves it changes back to
its original size so you wouldn't even
notice that it's 150 percent of its
normal size so let's try it out and
let's see now
Oh oops okay I forgot to change this to
if the exposition is less than negative
480 or actually a negative 479 so since
the left edge of the screen is negative
240 and the entire size of this costume
is 480 then half of the costume size is
going to be 240 and then once you
subtract 240 from negative 240 then that
is the rightmost edge of the sprite at
the leftmost edge so yeah that was again
sort of confusing uh sorry but it should
make sense visually so now let's try it
out again and as you can see now the
hill smoothly goes from the left side to
the right side so let's see it again and
all right so it works cool and I'm
actually gonna quickly add a dark green
outline because I think the light green
is sort of too close to the light blue
color of the sky so yeah I'm gonna
quickly add a line over here
all right so I'm done with my outline I
just pretty much added a line and then I
just reshaped it using this tool to fit
the hill all right so now I think it
looks better let's try it again
and as you can see there's the hill and
then teleports back so now we need to
add the second Hill because once the
hill is moving then there's a lot of
empty space and we don't want that so to
add a second Hill all we need to do is
to go to control and then create clone
of myself all right and we want to make
the clone do the exact same thing as the
original sprite however the only
difference will be that the clone is
shifted to the right of the sprite so
let's grab a when I star as a clone then
let's go to motion and then let's drag
this go to X 480 and then y 0 and to
make sure to go to looks grab the set
size to 150 put it before the go to X Y
and then grab the set size 100 and then
put it after since we want the clone to
go completely off screen so yeah anyway
since the clone is going to have exactly
the same code as the original sprite
we're gonna create a block so let's go
to my blocks and then make a block let's
call this move then let's click OK all
right now we have move and now we want
to drag this set size to 150 and stuff
like that into the move and now we can
drag our move block inside of the
forever loop and okay so my move block
did not appear um that sometimes happens
so I'm just gonna refresh the page there
we go so now there is the move block and
let's put this inside of the forever
loop and for the clone let's just
duplicate this for loop and then put it
under the stuff over here
alright so now the original sprite and
the clone both follow the same
code in the move block so it's sort of
simpler because if I want to change
something all I need to do is change
this one move block instead of you know
changing two separate blocks like this
so all right now let's see how it looks
so as you can see there is now a
infinite scrolling hill background and
it looks very smooth and yeah alright so
I think there's a tiny difference in the
line I just drew so I'm gonna fix it
real quick let's see it's over here okay
let's try it again
yeah you can barely tell that I have two
Hills so yeah alright so now that we're
done with the hill background we can't
add the chicken and the pipes back so
let's show the chicken then reconnect
the blocks then go to the pipes
reconnect the blocks also and now you
try it out and okay the hills are in
front of both the chicken and the pipes
so we want them to go back so let's go
to looks and grab a go backwards let's
say ten layers to make sure that it
actually goes back and I'll let's drag
this um in the wind flag clicked before
it creates a clone of itself and now it
works like this alright cool now we have
sort of some parallax going on which is
pretty much on the hill moves to the
left slower than the pipes do so yeah
now we have our infinite background and
now we're going to make a simple scoring
system so let's go to the pipes and
let's see we want to first create a
score variable so let's go to variables
then create a variable let's call this
score
then for all sprites and they click okay
all right so what we want to do is that
if the bird goes past the middle of the
pipes that we want the score to
increased by one so to do that we have
to go into pipes and then we want to
check if the exposition of the bird is
greater than the exposition of the pipes
so let's go to operators and grab a
greater than operator and let's go to
sensing grab the BACtrack number of
stage block and change the stage to
sprite one which is the bird and now we
have our exposition of sprite one so if
the exposition of the bird is greater
than the pipe exposition so motion and
then exposition then we want to go to
variables and then change score by one
all right now we want to put this inside
of the repeat until and now as the pipes
are moving to the left it's going to
constantly check so now there's a one
problem though whenever the bird is
passed the pipes the score goes up by a
lot because it keeps checking and the
score keeps going up but we only want
the score to go up once so to fix that
we can just simply create a variable
let's name this already scored so
already scored and we want to select for
this sprite only this is a very
important for the sprite only Dennis
cook okay and let's see where is my
variable hmm all right so there it is
already scored so what we're gonna do is
the first set already scored to no
because when the pipes spawn then the
bird hasn't gone through them yet so of
course the bird has not
scored so let's set this to no put it on
before everything in the if and repeat
until loops and now we want to check if
the bird has not yet already scored then
we want to change score by one so let's
go to operators grab an and and its grab
to equal and it's go to variables grab
already scored and it's check if already
scored is equals to no now let's drag
this over here into the left side and
let's put it back so of course it also
checks if the bird has already scored
and if it's no then it changes score by
one but of course once it changes the
score by one then it has scored so we
don't want this to call again so we just
set already scored to yes
so now it's only going to call once so
let's try it out all right and it
doesn't quite work the score goes up by
two so let's see I think to fix this I'm
going to make this set before the score
changes by one now let's try it again
okay still does not work let's see oh
yeah that is because we have both the
top and the bottom pipe so it acts as
two clones and it both check so what we
want to do is either only make the top
or the bottom pipe check so let's only
make the top pipe check so do that let's
grab another operator grab an and grab
an equals and let's see check if the
bottom or top pipe is equal to top now
let's drag this into the left side and
I'll check the entire thing back in let
me zoom out a bit alright
and now it should work so first it
checks if the exposition of the bird is
greater than the current pipe exposition
which means that the bird went past it
it also checks if the bird already
scored and also checks if the bottom or
top pipe is equal to top then if all of
these are true then it sets already
scored - yes and then it train a score
by one now let's try it out first of all
I'm going to set the score to zero
whenever the flag is clicked and now it
should be good so as you can see the
score changes by one every time so yeah
all right it works cool let me try it
again
and yeah now I have both my scrolling
background and the score counter the
game also ends when the bird touches the
bottom of the screen like this
this is part three on how to make a
flappy bird game in scratch in this
video I will be making the pipe skill on
screen and off screen more smoothly add
a number counter for the score and add a
simple Luo screen anyways let's get
started with the pipes so if you see the
pipes right now they sort of suddenly
appear at the edge of the screen and
they don't really smoothly appear and
they also disappear before they can
completely go off screen like that so
I'm gonna fix that
so let's first go to the pipes and then
let's do the same thing we did for the
background so in the last video I made
the background be able to go on screen
and off screen smoothly by first setting
its size to a larger size than the
actual size we want and then we position
the background to where we want it and
then we set the size back to its
original size so let's do the same thing
for the pipes so let's go to the pipes
and then right before it spawns let's go
to looks and then grab a set size too
and let's change this to like 150% and
then drag it right before go to XY and
then let's drag a set size to 100% right
after the go to XY and now let's change
the X to like maybe 270 to completely
make sure that the pipe is starting off
screen and before the top pipe let's do
the same thing so set size to 150% but
it before and then set size to a hundred
percent put it after so let's try it out
and they still don't entirely start off
screen so okay I think it should work
after we also set size to 150 percent
and a hundred percent before and after
it changes X by negative five so let's
try it out so let's drag this before we
change X by negative five and then drag
this after the change X by negative five
so now let's try it again
yeah I think that works the pipes as you
can see spawn from the right side of the
screen smoothly they don't you know sort
of randomly appear from the edge so yeah
and now let's fix the pipes leaving this
screen so right now it's still a bit
choppy when they leave the screen like
that let's see it again
yep so still a bit choppy so to fix that
all we need to do is to change this x
position to a smaller number so maybe
let's say if X position is less than 200
and I mean negative 260 now let's try it
out
oops okay let's try it again
let me first reattach this and all right
so let's see and cool they also leave
the screen smoothly so yeah I think we
fix the pipes and all right now that we
have the pipes fixed now I'm going to
make a number counter for the score so
instead of using this variable I'm going
to use actual numbers and that just
makes the game look a bit better so yeah
let's first create a new sprite and just
paint 10 costumes with the number 0
through 9 so yeah
[Music]
and yeah so now I have the numbers 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 and then 0 so the costume
names don't matter but the order matters
so make sure it's 1 through 9 and then 0
at the end so all right now let's go
back to the code and let's first grab a
win flag clicked then let's hide the
original sprite because we're gonna be
using clones for this and then let's
create a variable let's name this I
guess digits and then select for the
sprite only remember this is very
important for this part only because
each clone is going to have a different
value for the variable so if you do for
all sprites then it's not gonna work
because whenever the variable changes in
value then all of the clones are going
to have the same value for that variable
so we want the clones to have separate
values for the digits variable so select
for this part only and then click OK
all right by the way if your variable
doesn't show up immediately after you
created it then you can just refresh the
page and it should show up but anyways
let's grab a set digits to block and
let's set the digits to 1 and let's drag
this after Bhide now let's go to control
grab a repeat loop and then let's grab a
crate cloning myself and then go to
variables and let's grab a change digits
by one and this just creates 10 clones
each with a different value of the
digits so anyways now we want the clones
to do stuff right so let's go to events
I'll show your control sorry and then
let's drag a when I start as a clone
then we want the clone to show or
actually not show yet but yeah so let's
go to control grab a forever loop put it
under the when I star as a clone and
then we want the clones to go to a
specific
based on its digits favorable so let's
go to a motion and then drag a go to Y
position sorry a go to XY position and
then let's go to variables grab the
digits variable and then go to operators
grab the multiplication operator let's
drag the digits variable inside of the
left side of the operator and let's say
let's multiply this by 10 now let's drag
this inside of the exposition of the go
to X Y and let's place this inside of
the forever loop so if I just run this
what this does is that poops okay I need
to show the clones for now so yep all
right so if I run this then what this
does is that it creates ten clones and
they are all spaced apart by 10 pixels
and this is because each clone has a
different digits value because when I
first set digits to one and then created
a clone the clone I created the first
time had the digits value set to one but
then since I changed digits by one the
next clone I created has the value of
digits to two now and if I change it
again and then create another clone then
the third clone I created has the value
of digits to three so that's how it
works
each clone I create has a different
value of digits but yeah anyways now we
want the clones to show or hide based on
the score so let's say right now the
score is two then we only want the ones
place clone to show or this one and then
we want all the other ones to hide so do
that let's grab an if-else statement to
any control drag that in the forever
loop and then we want to check if the
length of the score is less than its own
variable of digits so let's grab a
lesser than operator and then let's grab
a length of
and let's go to variables and then drag
the score variable inside of the length
of drag this into the left side and
check if the length of score is less
than digits so if it is that means we
don't need that number and then we just
hide it otherwise we want it to show
so now as you can see since the score
was 2 now only one of the digits to show
so let's say the score was maybe like
270 now all three of them show so yeah
now we want these clones to show the
correct number so to do that let's go to
looks and if you want them to switch
costume based on their digit in the
score so to do that lets go to operators
grab the letter operator or actually
letter 1 of Apple and then let's replace
the one with digits and then Apple with
score now let's drag this inside of the
switch costume - then let's drag this
under the show so based on their own
digits 1 2 & 3 they're going to show the
letter of the score so 1 2 & 3 so yeah
as you can see this shows the correct
score now let's reposition this to the
top so I'm just change this Y value to
maybe 150 mm maybe 155 and I think
that's fine and now we can hide the
score variable now I think I'm going to
want my score to be in the middle but
however there is a problem so since the
scores in the middle when the length of
the score increases I still want my
score to stay in the middle so right now
it's not gonna work let's say I set the
score to a really high number let's say
like this and this score
has one two three four seven digits so
let's set it and as you can see this
number is not in the middle because it's
still in the same x position so um I
want to fix that so that this number is
in the middle no matter how many digits
the score is so to do that let's grab a
length of score so length of and then
score and we want this to move back
based on the length of the score right
so now let's go to operators grab a
multiplication operator drag this on the
left side and make sure to multiply this
by the same number you multiplied the
digits by so in my case it would be ten
and now we want to subtract this from
the original exposition so let's grab a
minus operator
drag this on the left side drag this on
the right side and oh yeah one more
thing since we want the score to stay in
the middle we want to divide this by two
so let's put this on the left side and
then divide by two
all right now let's drag this inside of
the minus operator and drag this back so
as you can see the number is now in the
middle let's try it out so let's say the
score is zero
then into the middle now let's try 100
still in the middle let's try a thousand
and it's still in the middle all right
and just to make this more clear like
these numbers here I'm gonna create a
variable and all those name this space
between digits I guess that'll click
okay and I'll just set this to 10
and then drag this to replace the tent
all right now it's more clear and it's
also easier to change because I can just
change this variable to increase or
decrease the space so I think I'm going
to increase it to maybe 12 and all right
I think that looks good so yeah now
let's try it out and let's see how the
score variable works all right it looks
pretty good
so I'm gonna try to get to 10 oops okay
let me try again
so we have zero right now one two three
four
dang it okay let me try again okay I
don't think I'm gonna get to ten but
let's just assume that the score miracle
works based on my testing so yeah now
that we fix the pipes and added a number
counter now I'm going to add a loose
screen so right now when the bird
touches the pipes then the game stops
and that's sort of boring I want the
player to be able to maybe have an
option to restart the game so to do that
let's create a new sprite and I am just
going to create a simple Luo screen
so now I have my loose screen and this
is gonna show up when the game ends so
let's go to the code and I actually want
this to be transparent so um let's just
grab a win flag clicked then let's go to
looks grab this set color effect to zero
and change this to ghosts
and let's change this to maybe 50 okay
maybe less so 20 and all right maybe a
15 actually and now this loose screen is
sort of transparent so now I'm going to
create another sprite and this is going
to be for the retry button
[Music]
all right so now I am done with the
retry button and I also changed the lose
screen by adding a crying bird so yeah
anyways um let's start with the blue
screen or actually oh yeah for the retry
button I want it to be transparent too
so let's also grab a set ghost effect
2:15 let me change that to maybe 25 or
30 all right so let's go to the loo
screen so um we want to first hide this
when the flag is clicked however we want
this to show when the bird loses so
let's go to the bird and right here in
the if touching sprite - or Y position
is less than negative 171 we want to
broadcast a message to tell the loose
screen that the bird lost so let's go to
control or actually uh event and then
broadcast a new message let's just call
this lose and let's put this in the if
touching sprite - or Y position is less
than negative 171 and instead of stop
all let's just stop this script so the
bird would just stop all of this and
stop moving so yeah all right now in our
loose screen we want to grab a when I
receive lose then we want the loose
screen to show so we just grab a show
and this should be good let's also do
the same thing for the retry button so
when I receive lose then show otherwise
when the flag is clicked then hide so
yeah let's try it out right now so when
the bird crashes into the pipe then
there so you lose and we see that the
bird stopped moving
however the pipes are still moving so to
fix that let's just go to the pipes and
then
at a when I received lose then let's
stop all and change this to stop other
scripts in sprite so by doing that it
just stops this block over here and this
block over here so now let's try it
again when the bird Falls let's say then
everything stops
oh yeah except for the background so
let's go to the background and drag a
when I receive lose then stop other
scripts in the sprite all right let's
try now and now as you can see
everything stops now we want the
sweetheart button to actually work
because right now this doesn't do
anything so let's go to the retry button
and then let's see inside of the when I
receive lose we want to drag in a farver
loop and let's drag in if-else statement
and then let's go to sensing let's
detect if mouse is down then let's say
let's make the retry button a bit darker
so let's go to looks and then grab the
set color effect 2-0 drag this inside of
the if Mouse down let's change this to
brightness and let's set this to maybe
negative 10 so this makes it darker
let's try it out oh yeah sorry I meant
if touching mouse pointer not if Mouse
down
so let's actually change that let's go
to sensing grab a touching mouse pointer
and let's replace the mouse down and now
let's try it out so as you can see it's
now darker however if the mouse pointer
is not touching the budget anymore we
want it to go back to its original
brightness so let's go to looks grab the
set brightness Effect 2 and let's change
it back to zero all right now let's try
it out and as you can see there is a bit
of a
but in touching effect all right so now
we want it to detect if the mouse
pointer is down and then we want to
restart the entire game so let's go to
control grab an if statement put this
inside of the if touching mouse pointer
and now we drag the mouse down inside
with the if statement and if the mouse
is down then we want to let's say
broadcast a new message so let's go to
events and broadcast a new message let's
just say play now let's drag this inside
of the if Mouse down let's also stop
this entire script after it broadcasts
play so that it doesn't keep on
broadcasting play so let's just drag a
stop all and change this to solve the
sprite or stop the script so right now
it's not gonna do anything and that's
because we need the sprites to restart
to all of their actions when the play is
broadcasted
so let's first go to the chicken and
instead of the ones I clicked let's
replace that with the when I receive
play like this all right let's do the
same for the pipes so instead of the
ones I clicked we want the winner
receive play then it does all that and
for the background let's replace the win
flag clicked and for the number counter
replace the wind flag clicked and then
for the you lose replace the one for I
clicked and also for the retry button
alright so now that we replaced all of
the wind fly clicked with plays that
means that now all this is replayable
as long as we call the play message then
all of this is going to restart however
when we click the flag we still want to
broadcast play right because we want to
start the game when we click the flag so
yeah I'm just gonna put this inside of
the chicken and now it should work so it
starts the game everything works as
normal until we lose and then we start
and everything restarts however as you
can see there are some problems so let's
go to the pipes and I think the problem
is because the clones don't get deleted
when the lose message is broadcasted so
let's grab a delete this clone after I
receive lose so all of the clones from
the previous game should get deleted now
let's try it again so when the bird
crashes to the pipe and then restarts
then it works all right cool and one
thing for the number counter it's
actually better to probably add a win
flag clicked then do all this stuff
because we only need to do this once
when the green flag is clicked so yeah
now this should be good so oh yeah since
there's also a clone for the background
to make sure there aren't any extra
clones on the screen when I restart then
we want to delete the clone so yeah now
I think this should be good oh yeah okay
I forgot to stop other scripts in this
sprite for the number counter so let's
just do that just in case so when I
receive lose then stop other scripts in
this sprite all right and we don't want
to delete these clones because we're
only creating them once when the flag is
clicked so yeah now let's try it again
so everything works as normal then when
we lose
then there's a loose screen and then if
we retry then everything works as normal
oops okay except for the number counter
so let's see okay actually let me just
still add a delete this clone after
loose and then let's replace the ones I
clicked with when I receive play all
right now I think this should work let's
try it out so everything works as normal
then we retry and it works all right
cool
so now we have a replayable game and
okay what happened here that's weird oh
yeah that was because my mouse pointer
was on the retry button so yeah but yeah
this works alright let's see and you
lose and then we try and then it
restarts all right cool
this is part 4 on how to make a flappy
bird game in scratch in this tutorial I
will be making some improvements to the
loose screen adding a countdown text and
adding a menu screen so first off our
clones of the pipe and the hills don't
show up when the game is over and that's
because we delete the clones when the
game is over since we don't want the
clones to reappear when the game
restarts however we still want them to
show when the ulugh screen pops up but
we can't really put the delete this
clone after the when I receive play
because it wouldn't really work so let's
just say for the pipes for example I
moved the jelly disk loan from the when
they received lose to when I receive
play then if you try it then we lose and
then restart then there's these clones
of these pipes and this still doesn't
work so to fix this we need to broadcast
a message after the win and receive lose
but before the when I receive play and
this way we can safely delete our clones
in between the losing and the play so
I'm going to first put this back and
alright this also ties in perfectly with
making the countdown text because the
countdown is going to happen after the
you lose but before the game starts so
what I was thinking for the countdown is
that when the game starts it's going to
show up like a 3 2 1 start and then the
game's gonna actually start like this so
when the countdown is happening the
games gonna actually be paused but yeah
so let's make the countdown text let's
first create a new sprite and I'm just
gonna type in the number 3 alright I'll
make this a bit larger like this and
then I'll duplicate this I'll type in to
do create this again type in 1 and then
duplicate this is again then I'll type
go then I'll make sure to Center this in
the middle
all right so on the screen over here
it's gonna be three two one go so this
is gonna be our countdown text all right
so currently when the green flag is
clicked we broadcast play however we
don't want to do that because we want to
broadcast our countdown text to start
instead so let's create a new message
and I'll just call this start countdown
all right
click OK and then when the green flag is
clicked we want to actually broadcast
start countdown so let's go to our
countdown sprite in their countdown
sprite we want to receive the start
countdown and then when it receives it
we want to first show it and then let's
go to motion make sure it goes to X Y
zero zero so it's in the center like
this and then we want to go to looks and
then switch costume to costume 1 which
is the number 3 and then go to control
let's wait maybe 0.5 seconds and then
let's actually duplicate this switch
costume and wait so duplicate this and
then put it under then we want to switch
costume to costume 2 which is the number
2 and then weigh 0.5 seconds and then
duplicate this again switch costume to
costume 1 or actually 3 sorry and then
switch costume to costume 4 which is the
go so it's gonna be like this 3 2 1 go
and then at the end we actually want to
hide this so go to looks and then hide
it so it's like this 3 2 1 go and then
hide all right so if we try it right now
then we have our countdown but we
actually want the countdown to start the
game after it's finished so at the end
over here let's go to events and then
broadcast
play after it finished counting down so
let's try it again three two one go and
then the game starts alright cool
however we still want the game to
initialize when the green flag is
clicked because right now there's like
nothing right and then when the game
starts then everything is put into place
but we want everything to be ready when
the countdown is counting down like this
so to do that it's actually pretty easy
we have to just go to every sprite and
then make sure it's in the correct place
when it receives the countdown message
so for example in the chicken we want it
to set it's change in Y to zero so
that's not moving and then go to this
position and then set size to eighty and
that's going to be under when I receive
start tamp down so just change that and
then for the rest of the actual moving
script let's just drag a when I receive
play so by doing this the chickens
actually in its starting position when
the countdown happens like this all
right cool so now time to do the pipes
so let's see I think for the pipes it's
fine
because when the countdown is happening
we don't want any pipes of spawn so the
pipes are okay but let's see the hills
so of course when it receives the
countdown we want the hill to be in the
middle so go to zero zero and then go
backwards ten layers so in the very back
and I think this is fine and then we can
just drag this back inside of the win
and receive play and let's see how it
looks so the hills in the correct
position alright and now I think the
only thing missing is the number counter
or the score counter so let's go to the
score counter and let's see let's change
the win and receive plate two when they
receive start countdown so pretty much
the score counter creates all of its
clones and then the clones show and
stuff like that
when the score starts counting down or
the count down sprite starts counting
down sorry
so yeah let's try it out now oh yeah and
we also need to hide our you lose screen
and retry button when the countdown
starts so let's go to our you lose
sprite and change the play to start
countdown and do the same thing for a
retry button change the win and receive
play - when I receive start countdown
alright let's try to get now there's the
countdown and then the game starts
alright cool
let's try it again there's the countdown
and then the game starts alright so the
countdown now works when the green flag
is clicked however the countdown does
not work yet when the retied button is
clicked and that is because for the
retry button when the button is clicked
it broadcasts play but we need to change
that to count down or start countdown so
when the mouse is down then broadcast
start countdown alright let's try it
again
so countdown and then let's just say we
lose the game then we try and then
there's the countdown alright cool so we
added the countdown and the countdown
seems to work alright but however we
still need to fix the problem with the
loose screen because the clones are
disappearing so to prevent the clones
from deleting when the loose screen
starts up
let's move the delete this clone into
the when I receive start countdown not
after when I receive loose so let's
first go to our pipes and then where it
says delete this clone inside of the
when I receive loose let's change this
to when I receive start countdown and
then delete this clone and the same
thing for the hills so instead of the
delete this clone inside of the winner
received loose we drag a rash in here
when I receive start countdown then
delete this clone alright let's try it
now so there's a countdown
then let's lose the game and now as you
can see the pipes show up and the hill
shows up and for some reason our retry
button is in the back over here so I'm
just going to make it go to the front
layer when the lose is received all
right let's try it again count down and
then lose this game and then there we go
now we have a fully functioning loo
screen cool so I'm just try it out it's
like this and then when the game is lost
then essentially everything pauses and
it's all good all right so now I sort of
wanted to add a bird knock-back
animation when the game loses for
example when the bird crashes into the
pipe the bird sort of jumps backwards
like that so I'm going to add that let's
go to the bird sprite and then since we
want the bird to do its animation when
the game is lost let's grab a when I
receive lose then let's make the bird
sort of jump so we want to of course
change the or actually set the change in
Y to let's say 7 now we want to go to
control and then grab a repeat until
block put it after the change in Y to 7
and then let's repeat until the bird is
lower than the bottom edge of the screen
so our P until the Y position is less
than what is it I think I have it over
here
oh yeah negative 171 all right
drag this inside of the repeat until and
then after the bird is lower than
negative 171 in the Y position then it's
going to hide so Jack B hide after the
repeat until and then while it's still
greater than negative 171 then we want
it to just duplicate this so change Y by
changing Y drag inside of the repeat
until
and then we want to also make sure the
change in Y is decreasing so also copy
this one change change in Y by negative
0.8 and then drag this inside of there
repeat until all right so let's try it
out so when the bird crashes into the
pipe then it sort of jumps like that all
right I think I'm gonna make the bird
also go backwards a bit so let's go to
motion and that drag a change X by let's
say negative 1 that's dragon in there
and let's try it out
oops okay and our bird is hidden that is
because I hit it over here but then I do
not show it again when the game starts
so let's go to looks and then grab a
show drag it after the when I receive
start countdown all right let's try it
again there's the bird when it hits the
pipe then it does that all right cool
let's see it again the bird when it hits
the pipe let's say here it sort of jumps
backwards all right and I'm also going
to make sure that the bird points in
direction of 90 degrees when the game
starts all right and I think it works so
let's see oh yeah I realized that the
score does not reset until the start
countdown finishes but we want the score
to reset when you start countdown begins
so let's see where the score is set over
right here all right and let's actually
set the score when I receive start
countdown all right now the score resets
to zero when the start countdown begins
and it should be fine all right cool
like this okay
and now I sort of remember seeing some
bugs when I was play testing this game
so let me just try to find them
let's see oh yeah right there
when you press retry before the bird is
finished falling it sort of doesn't work
like that because the bird is still
falling so let's go to our bird and
let's see it stops all other scripts in
the sprite so let's put it before
everything over here and that is because
when the game restarts while the bird is
still falling then the bird is going to
keep on falling so we need to make sure
that we stop the falling bird sprite or
script and then it should work all right
let's try it again so when the bird is
falling and then it clicked we try then
it works let's see I remember seeing
something else that was a problem I
think it was the pipes so let's see okay
I don't see anything right now
okay that's a problem so I think when
you press me try right after the bird
dies then it doesn't work so let's try
it
oops okay it's right here so I'm just
gonna spam click this and then yeah the
game doesn't really work so let's see
how I can fix this
hmm let's see it again
all right so that just stops working so
I think the best way to fix this is to
just go to the retry button and then
adding a wait let's say 0.1 seconds
before it runs the code about the
touching the mouse pointer and stuff
like that so I think they should fix it
I'm gonna try it again alright that
fixes it so when I click it super
rapidly there's no more weird pipe
issues so that's fine
alright cool so I think I fixed all of
the bugs for now now I'm going to create
a simple menu screen so first of all I
need to create a menu button so let's
just duplicate this retry button and
then let's go to costumes and I'm gonna
change this to menu and yeah that should
be fun
alright so now I'm going to position
this downwards a bit maybe right here
alright so I'm just gonna drag this go
to X Y let's say after the when I
receive lose and fourthly you retry
button I'm gonna do the same so go to 0
0 alright so now I have the retry and
menu button so when I click the menu
button I want it to broadcast a new
message and let's just name this menu
when we click the menu button you want
it to actually go to the menu so let's
go to stage and then I'm going to create
a new backdrop and this is gonna be my
menu backdrop and for now I'm just gonna
create a rectangle that's the color
white or actually a light blue works too
so like this all right bit wider okay
and then I'm just gonna add some text
saying menu and this should be fine for
now alright so now in our stage we want
to make sure that when it receives menu
so an event when I receive menu then we
want to switch backdrop to backdrop -
which is the menu backdrop and then when
I receive start countdown which is the
game starting with the countdown text
then we want to switch backdrop to
backdrop 1 which is our game background
so yeah right now it should work with
just the background change alright and
then menu and like that the menu changes
however if we go to the menu we want
everything else to disappear so let's go
to the sprites one by one and then make
sure the high when they receive menu so
let's first go to the bird alright so
let's go to events when I receive menu
then we want to hide and then go to
control Raschi events or sorry control
and then stop other scripts in sprite
alright so this ensures that nothing
else in the chicken sprite is going to
run
and that should be fine now let's drag
this into also our pipe sprite and let's
add a delete this clone at the end to
make sure all the clones are gone and
then drag this into our Hill sprite
alright drag this into our number
counter sprite also our loose screen
however we don't need this delete this
clone since there are no clones in this
blue screen and we also don't need this
stop other scripts in sprite since there
are no loops in here so it's fine and
let's go to let's say our number counter
and then drag this into our retry button
sprite let's take out the delete this
clone because there are no clones in
this sprite and I think there should be
fine oh yeah also the menu button
alright and it should be good let's try
it out countdown and then lose the game
then menu oh yeah this is another bug
when you lose the game right win a pipe
is spawned then the pipe still moves
because the stock other scripts in
sprite is called right before the pipe
starts moving so yeah I am going to fix
this in the next part of the series
though but anyways let's go back to
looking at the menu so let's try it
again when the bird loses then menu then
as you can see everything hides and we
are at the menu so now on the menu
screen we want a play button so to do
that let's just copy the menu button and
that's go to costumes change this to
play or actually start and then let's go
to the code and let's see in the window
receive menu we want the button to show
and actually do all this stuff
so we
take this out and then change the loose
to menu and this should be fine and then
when the mouse is down we want a start
button to broadcast play or actually
start countdown and then that should be
fine let's see alright and when I
receive start countdown we want the
start button to hide and also to stop
other scripts in the sprite oh actually
oh we already have it here so it's fine
yep that's good and I think we should be
good so let's try it out
oops okay everything is gone or actually
the hills and that's because I need to
make sure I show the hills when the
start countdown is received like that
alright let's try it out
okay then when the bird crashed the pipe
and then menu then there's our start
button alright and then when we press
Start then there is our countdown okay
everything seems normal and everything
seems to work now I'm just going to
reposition the start button to maybe the
middle over here so right here
that is why position 23 all right and
there should be good menu and then menu
alright now since we have a menu when
the green flag is clicked we don't want
it to start the game but we want it to
go to the menu so instead of
broadcasting start countdown we wanted
to broadcast menu and now it should be
fine
so when the green flag is clicked it
shows the menu and then we can start
alright and our game works like normal
and then when the bird crashes it shows
the animation
and then we can retry and we can also go
to the menu alright so there we have it
we have our basic menu we have a working
retry button and LU screen and we also
added some countdown text
this is part 5
how to make a flappy bird game in
scratch and in this video I am going to
make the menu look better add some
sound-effects fix some bugs and we
explain all the code in the project
anyways let's get started so the first
thing I want to fix before I do anything
else is that I forgot to make it so that
you can't hold the mouse button because
right now when you hold the mouse button
the bird sort of floats up and we don't
want that because we only want the bird
to jump once when you tap the button and
if you hold the button the bird still
only jumps once so that's what we want
so to do that we just actually have to
go to control and then grab a wait until
block go to operators grab a knot and
then go to sensing and then grab a mouse
down and let's drag this after the set
change in Y and point in direction
inside of the if Mouse down and now what
this does is that after you hold the
mouse button down it runs the set
changed Y and point in direction and
then you have to release the mouse
pointer before running this again so now
this prevents the player from holding
down the mouse button however we can't
put this if Mouse down inside of this
forever loop anymore because while it's
waiting for knob Mouse down then nothing
else would run so we want to separate
this if Mouse down from the forever loop
and then let's just go to events grab a
separate when I receive play and then
grab a forever loop from the control and
then drag this if Mouse down stuff
inside of the forever loop all right now
let's try it out
all right and then if I try holding then
the bird still jumps like normal let me
try it again like this if I hold then
the bird still only jumps once all right
cool so we fix that problem and
something else that may happen when you
play the game is that when you lose the
game right when another clone of the
pipe spawns the cloned pipe keeps
moving normally across the screen
instead of freezing so let's go to the
pipes to see what's wrong
let's see what can we fix in here okay
let me first try to recreate the bug so
I have to crash into the pipe right when
a new pipe spawns okay that was a bit
too late let me try it again
okay a bit too early now let me see
okay still a bit too early okay a bit
too late now all right so I managed to
get the bug and as you can see the newly
spawned pipe keeps scrolling through the
screen and we don't want that so let's
go to our pipes now and I think what
happens is that the pipe creates a clone
at the exact same time that the bird
loses and then it's supposed to stop all
other scripts in this bite but it
doesn't stop the Krait clone of myself
because it's the exact same time and
then that ends up the newly created
clone not stopping all of its scripts
and then keep on going so that's the
problem I think so to fix that we have
to create a new variable and then I'll
just call this lost and then yep click
OK and when the flag is clicked or
actually when I receive a play or
actually start countdown let's set lost
to no and then once the bird crashes
into the pipe then we want to set lost
to yes so let's go to the bird
and then right here in the if touching
sprite to which is the pipe then we want
to set lost to yes and then do all this
all right now let's go back to our pipe
and in the clone over pipe we want to
make sure that the pipe only moves if
lost is equal to no otherwise we want
the pipe to pause so let's go to control
grab an if statement and then go to
operators we have an equals and then go
to variables grab a lost and then check
if lost is equal to no then do all of
this stuff inside of the repeat until
oops I'm gonna make sure that I also get
the set size to 150 percent in there all
right so let's try it out I'm gonna try
to make sure that bird loses right when
the pipe spawns to see if the problem is
fixed all right I'm gonna go to a
project view so it's a bit easier and
let's try it so let me make sure that
the pipe just spawns okay that was a bit
too late I think okay but too early now
okay a bit too early again I think I
need to be like one frame later okay
that's too late okay so I can't recreate
the exact problem that we used to have
but I'm pretty sure the problem is fixed
so let's go back inside it of the
project and okay hmm let me first
reposition the you loose screen I think
it accidentally dragged it so I'll just
drag it go to zero zero after the when I
received lose all right and now that I
think all of the bugs are fixed I'm
going to create a better looking menu
[Music]
all right so I am done with the menu and
I separated the title into a new sprite
so instead of putting it inside of the
backdrop I made it its own separate
sprite and that's because I want the
title to maybe move around a bit so yeah
and I also added some sun rays and I
made these a separate sprite also
because I'm gonna add some ghost effect
because I want the Rays to be
transparent so yeah anyways I made the
button look a bit better and added some
hills in the background and yeah
alright so I'm gonna first go to the
Sunbeam sprite and then I'm going to go
to a control or actually events and then
drag a when I receive menu then I'm
gonna go to looks and then I'm going to
set the ghost effect to maybe let's try
50 all right um let's try 40 maybe 30
and I like 40 better all right and then
I'm also gonna make them go to the back
so go to back layer alright and I think
they look better
and now for the title I am also going to
drag a when I receive menu then I think
I'm gonna make the title go up and down
by a tiny bit so I'm going to my guess
grab a repeat and then I'm going to
repeat maybe 10 times and I'm going to
change Y by let's say 0.5 and then I'm
going to duplicate this and then change
Y by negative 0.5 and let's see how this
looks
alright so it goes up and down like that
okay so I think we can repeat this so
let's go to control and then grab a for
loop and put this around the two repeats
in the sea and it jumps up and down like
that all right
also I'm going to grab a win I receive
start town town then I am going to hide
the sprite and then stop all other
scripts in the sprite so in control and
then stop other scripts in sprite and
also for my sunbeams I'm gonna do the
same thing so when I receive start
countdown then hide and we don't need
the stop other scripts in the sprite
because there are no loops in here so
we're fine all right let's see
and okay our title is gone and we have
to reshow it so let's drag a show after
the when I received menu and also a show
for the sunbeams and that should be good
all right let's try it out so there's
the bouncing title and when we press
Start then the game starts as normal
all right cool so I think this is going
to be our title screen now and let's see
okay and now I'm going to make some
changes to the you lose screen
[Music]
all right so this is going to be our you
loose screen and for the retry and many
buttons I am going to take out the ghost
effect so I'm going to set it back to
zero so it's fully visible all right and
that should look better okay so now we
have our updated loose screen so let's
see it again and our loose screen right
here and lastly I am going to now add
some sound effects so let's see of
course we want a flapping sound effect
for our bird so let's go to our bird and
then let's go to sounds and now let's
create a new sound we can actually
choose a sound so the scratch 2.0 editor
has a great selection of sounds you can
choose from like all these so I'm gonna
try to find some maybe flapping sound
let me search it up flap
okay nothing let me go to effects
alright so low whoosh sounds pretty good
it sounds like this so let's select this
and I'm going to first trim this so
let's click this trim tool over here and
I'm just going to trim this much of it
and then click Save and now let's see I
might make it slower
okay bit slower okay I think that's fine
for now so let's go back to our code and
to add the sound it's really easy all we
need to do is in our if Mouse down we
just want to go to sound and then add a
play sound low whoosh so let's put this
right after and that should be fine so
let's try it out now when the bird flaps
there's the low whoosh sound all right
cool so I think that sounds pretty good
and oh yeah we don't want the sound to
play when we're selecting a button
though like if we click retry then the
sound still plays and we don't want that
so let's see I think in our when I
receive lose we can go to control and
then grab a stop other scripts in the
sprite and let's put it right after it
receives lose so this is where the bird
sort of jumps back when it like hits a
pipe or something so yeah now let's try
it out okay and then when the lose is
there is no more sound and all right it
works
so our flapping sound works for the bird
oops and that should be fine all right
so I think I also want a button sound so
when we hover over it there's the sort
of button click sound effect or
something like that so let's see let's
go to sounds again and let's try to find
the sound all right so I found a good
sound
it's called would tap sounds like this
so I think this is gonna be when we
hover over the button let's see I might
make it slower
actually this was fine so yeah
let's leave it like that okay this is
fine now let's go back to the code and
in all of our buttons we want to add
that would tap sound and okay I think it
accidentally added that to the loose
screen
so oops but we can just drop this sound
into our buttons like that so let's do
that and in our buttons
we can now add this when it's touching
the mouse pointer so let's go to sound
and then add the start sound would tap
let's place this after the if touching
mouse pointer or actually let's not do
that because it won't work because sense
this if statement is constantly checking
if it's touching the mouse pointer the
sound would constantly play so we don't
want that we only want the sound to play
once when the mouse enters the button
area so let's grab a separate event when
I receive lose and then let's grab a
forever loop and we can just grab an if
statement and then check if it's
touching the mouse pointer then we want
to start the sound would tap and then
let's go to control and wait until it's
not touching the mouse pointer and now
that should be fine so this ensures that
the sound only plays once when the mouse
pointer enters so let's try it out that
is for the retry button so let's go to
the retry button and then as you can see
the button sound plays all right so
let's do the same thing for the menu
button let's just drag this inside of
the menu sprite or menu button sprite
and then that should be fine because the
menu button sprite has almost the same
code as the retry button sprite so we're
good now let's drag this into our start
button ok and then instead of when I
receive lose we want this to be when I
receive menu now let's try it out
ok there's he start button sprite and ok
so this works fine like that however
first thing I noticed was that the
countdown sprite showed on the menu so
we want to
go to events drag a when I receive menu
then we want to hide the countdown
sprite alright and a second thing kind
of noticed was that when the game starts
you can still hover over the menu button
sprite because it's still there so let's
go to our Start button in our menu and
let's see oh yeah we have to make sure
that when the start button is clicked we
want to also stop other scripts in the
sprite including the button sound effect
so yeah that's why this was playing
because this Farva loop was still going
so now that we added the stop other
strips in sprite it stops everything in
the start button sprite alright let's
try it again
so there's our sound effect and okay
let's see oh yeah okay so the stop other
scripts in sprite also stopped this so
let's just drag this hide inside of the
if Mouse down and that should be fine
alright and there we go okay oh and I
think the same thing for the menu button
so we want to stop other scripts in the
sprite for the menu button and let's
also drag the hide inside of the if
Mouse down instead of the start
countdown and let's check the retry
button okay same thing so drag a stop
other scripts in sprite and that should
be fine oh yeah let's drag the hide
inside of the if Mouse down and let's
write again okay
all right okay our many button is still
there so let's see oh yeah we still have
to include the one I receive start
countdown because when we restart the
game we still have to hide the mini
button so yeah my bad let's drag this
back let's also drag this inside of the
retry button sprite just in case yeah
that should be fine all right okay the
money button is still running okay to
fix this we have to go to control and
then stop other scripts in the sprite
wind star countdown is received and that
should be fine let's do the same thing
for the retry button so stop other
scripts in sprite when start countdown
who's received and now let's try it
again okay all right
no more button tapping sound effects in
the game I mean when the game starts
alright
and I think that works okay cool
so we have the button sound effect down
and now I think I'm going to add a sound
effect to when the bird passes a pipe
maybe some like high-pitched ding sound
effect or maybe a bell or something so
let's try to find that let's see let's
go to our pipe let's see yep so let's go
to sounds now and I'm going to find the
sound okay I found the sound effect and
it's this sort of coin sound effect like
that so let's add this and I'm gonna
trim this to here and I might make this
higher pitched let's see okay yeah I
think a higher pitch sounds better okay
and now this is gonna be our score
increase sound effect so let's go to our
code and right in here when the bird
passes the position of the pipes then we
want to go to sounds and then start the
sound of the coin all rights try it out
alright there it is okay that seems
pretty good let's try it again
alright
and one more sound effect and I think I
will add is when the bird crashes into
the pipe we sort of need some bump sound
effect so let's go to our bird sprite
and then I will find a sound alright so
there weren't any small bumping sound
effects but I think beatbox one will do
so it's like this
so I think I'm gonna only use the first
part of the sound effect so when it does
this ok so right around here so I'm
gonna trim about this much of it let's
try it pip it more or hear all right so
I think this much is fine I'm gonna save
this alright and let's drag the sound
into when the bird crashes into the pipe
so right here let's drag the start sound
of beatbox one inside of the if touching
sprite to which is the pipe or if the Y
position is less than negative 171
alright let's try it out okay that
sounds pretty good let's try it again
when it falls off okay I think that's
good and of course you can record your
own sound effects if you want you can
also find them online there's some good
sites where you can download some free
sound effects but anyways that's pretty
much it so I'm just gonna do some more
playthroughs of the game so this is the
menu okay I'm gonna go to the project
page alright so this is the menu we have
our start this is our gameplay
let's crash into the pipe okay let me
try okay let's go back and let's start
again of course you can make the game
harder by decreasing the space between
the pipes all right
oops got some lag right there but yeah
anyways that's the entire game anyways
that's over this video and that's it for
this entire series